One of the most widely used security
services is the secure socket layer or
SSL and the follow on standard known
as the transport layer security or TLS.
TLS can be provided as part of
the underlying protocol suite and
therefore, all applications
above the transport layer
can benefit from the security
services provided by TLS.
Alternatively, TLS can be imbedded
in specific application packages.
For example,
most browsers come equipped with SSL and
most web servers have
implemented the protocol.
TLS is designed to make use
of TCP to provide a reliable
end to end secure service.
TLS is not a single protocol but
rather, two layers of protocols
as illustrated in this figure.
The record protocol provides
basic security services
to various higher layer protocols.
For example,
HTTP can operate on top of TLS.
Three higher layer protocols
are defined as part of TLS.
The Handshake Protocol,
the Change Cipher Spec Protocol, and
the Alert Protocol.
These TLS specific protocols are used
in the management of TLS exchanges.